[Music]
anybody a fan of the movie castaway me
yeah wait is that wilson yeah that was
wilson yeah featuring tom hanks it's a
great movie
hey hey do you guys uh at the end of the
movie right when he goes back and his
wife is like with another man that's
like his best friend and [__] would you
be like man [__] you [__] cheating
ass [__] yep yeah i wouldn't [__]
wait for me i would have had a gasoline
can and i just run around the house
smoke a cigarette like a cool guy and
then drop it in and then walk away i
want to beat the [__] out of the dude
and go i had to [__] cook with ice
case [__] ice skates dog yeah
dude i was making out with a coconut
while you were [__] my wife i was
[__] a volleyball guy yeah
yeah so uh actually a uh man recently
survived 18 hours at sea by clinging on
to a football like that 18 hours of that
[__]
hours this guy managed to survive 18
hours a drift at sea by holding onto a
ball that had been left behind
by boys at a beach 80 miles away
sometimes the pollution helps he just
found the
football we should help in the water and
he was like oh [__] helps some pollution
we should leave more balls in the ocean
i think yeah just as like life-saving
boys yeah just case of the castaway
situation a tourist named uh ivan was
swept out to sea by a powerful current
off the coast of cassandra in greece
as he pulled oh cheating ass
[__] has a warm water
[Music]
in the most beautiful [__] ocean you
know
it's clear blue and [__] little sharks
he's back stroking so we just got a deep
hot tub right
i'll do 20 hours man
i raise you [__] baseball too
a baseball give me a golf ball is that
even any air that you're just holding
and it's a it's a soccer ball i was
thinking about a [__] oval ass
football it's so slippery yeah european
football yeah yeah yeah oh come on
that's even more
american here
i thought he was holding on to laces you
know that's what i thought lace is out
yeah like a basketball or like any kind
of vault like a ball
in underwater yeah it's very helpful
shoots right out yeah it shoots right
out it does it's harder just like hold
on to it well i think it's hard when
you're trying to hold it under water but
if you just hold it and you're really
tired well you'll be like this have you
guys ever held the [__] baby boogie
board underwater as a kid and shot up
and hit you in the chin yeah yeah you
know like when this is like lame because
i played water polo in high school so
don't make fun of me
[Laughter]
shoot up dude water polo is one of the
most badass sports to be honest it is
but we said we used to have the
waterfall ball and we should be able to
sit under the like water and like kind
of be in a chair but like sit on top of
it because the pressure's going up and
then you can kind of like sit on it and
be chilling so you like to sit on balls
huh
is that an illegal move to do it during
a game yeah you can't put the ball under
water yeah so or they call you gay
[Laughter]
what's the point of calling everybody
gay when they're already gay i don't
know oh okay i don't know that's the
great debate
so as he was pulled further and further
away from the shore his uh panicked
friends raised the alarm with the greek
coast guard and he was declared lost at
sea but somewhat miraculously the 30
year old was saved when a small ball
floated towards him yeah
the ball had been lost on june 30th on
evgatis beach on the greek island of
lemnos by brothers triphon 11 and
six-year-old thanos did they log this
did they like journal that did they
should they report this to them lost my
ball today i'll never be the same maybe
fast forward 10 days and the ball made
his way past ivan who was able to grab
hold of it and soon discovered that it
helped him stay afloat when he started
to feel tired wait did you say one of
the brothers names was thanos yes is
that a trifan and thanos is that
considered like a greek name i think
they're just great names no it's a
marvel name it's different yeah i feel
like
i feel like you can't name your kid
[__] thanos bro he better be a giant
it does sound like a greek name right
thanos yeah that's type like a titan of
some sort maybe it's an abbreviation of
his real name
thanos
and anthony's
wikipedia thanos outside of the marvel
cinematic anthony's rome italian you'll
never get outside the marvel cinematic
universe i don't yeah i don't think
we're going to find
is it called edamame like what's edamame
etymology there it is derived from the
greek idea of thanatos the
personification of death in oblivion oh
that's
so they're really passing down the greek
names
so he grabs hold of it
ivan from north macedonia was finally
plucked from the water on july 10th
after a whopping 18 hours of sea when he
was found by rescuers he was still
clutching the ball how long can people
wait in the water until they [__] die
well if it's greek warm waters that's
just cheating at least 19. but then you
get tired because there's a lot of balls
well it depends on how uh uh how much
salt is in the water because the more
salty the more salty the water the
easier it is to just float and be
buoyant yeah but it's also [__] up
your skin though yeah i'll dehydrate you
too yeah
then you just drink you just drink it
when you're decoy yeah once you yeah as
long as you drink the water you're fine
right this [__] wasn't even from
a shipwreck no he got pulled out to sea
from the beach he was [__] around he
was gonna get around a loser yeah yeah
dude like he's like splashing in the
water whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
18 18 hours of that i know 18 hours of
whoa whoa whoa and he couldn't swim back
to shore
yeah i'm like what the [__] this was a
little [__] dude a little [__] dog
what's his name ivan i've been from
north macedonia lucky that soccer ball
saved you what if he's also a soccer
player so he doesn't want to grab it
with his hands he's all done with his
feet no matter what i don't have a rule
he's like there's a code to this thing
he has like his integrity as a player
yes there's a ball [__] it's a fool no
i'm not a goalie though
just grip with my knees
i stayed awake in the water was bouncing
it on my head
by the time they
get the ball out of the water by the
time they see him they just blow a
whistle on him because he's holding it
the coast guard's like the whole time
he's holding
gabe
he's calling him gay because he got he
got hit
oh snap i didn't even realize that there
was one other part of the story i never
saw yeah it just ends on the sentence
sadly his friend martin who was also
swept out to see at the same time
remains missing as of yesterday not
enough soccer
we got a little got swept out are you
sure dude you think you think they
fought for the ball
he pushed them off
the jack and rose situation
rose because they fought when ivan came
back he's like oh my friend wasn't with
me i don't know what you're talking
about i don't know where he is i haven't
survived
because they couldn't [__] share the
ball dude two dudes one ball two dudes
one ball that's a movie right there
and he had to drown his friend you had
to who would do it who would do it here
don't lie guys i'm so curious how long
but then someday that guy's gonna come
back and be like you bastard
yeah he's gonna come back to see me
yeah doesn't take it off you remember me
yeah and he's got a hook for a hand all
of a sudden i forgot like muscles and
barnacles and [__]
covered in particles he doesn't clean
any of it his face isn't octopus he's
got tentacles coming out of his chin
wait that's pirates caribbean dude
that's a way better aquaman story that
is a better aquaman story
yeah if it's an aquaman born out of
revenge that's way better because the
other one's too [__] any aquaman story
is a better aquaman story
jason how do you feel about aquaman the
franchise i like alpha man
that's why he didn't join in on the
jokes he's like i like aquaman i'm not
gonna take no [__]
so i'm not making fun of my favorite
movie i'm still like why didn't the guy
grab the ball with his hands
[Music]
[Applause]
you